everyone welcome to this next episode of
your daily equation yesterday we focused
on Einsteins e equals mc-squared today
we want to focus on a different equation
but related to equals mc-squared it's
the time dilation equation it's a
wonderful profound equation that in fact
allows us to seriously talk about a
certain kind of time travel not sort of
sci-fi time travel but unless the sci-fi
film is really good had good advisors
perhaps but real time travel written
into the laws of physics all right so
let's jump right into it the environment
the situation is very similar to that
which we discussed yesterday with equals
MC squared albert einstein is at the
Patent Office 1905 Bern Switzerland
thinking about the ways in which you
might synchronize clocks that are at a
distance from one another thinking about
light and its speed and he comes to this
wonderful and strange conclusion that
the speed of light is a fixed unchanging
constant number 671 million miles per
hour 300 million meters per second use
whatever units you like one light year
per year it doesn't matter the point is
that that number in whatever chosen
units is independent of who does the
measurement independent of the motion of
the source motion of the receiver a
fixed value for the speed of light the
speed of light is constant good okay now
why would this have any impact on our
understanding of time or even space and
time well the answer intuitively is
pretty straightforward as I discussed
yesterday speed is nothing but a measure
of how far you go compared to how long
it takes you to get there and how far
you go that's a distance that's a
measurement of space how long it takes
you to get there is time right it's a
duration it's how much time elapses and
so if speed behaves weirdly at say huge
speeds near the speed of light then
space and time must behave weirdly too
they are all in
caitli inter-connected and what Einstein
does in June of 1905 is he works out the
implications of the constant nature of
the speed of light on both space and
time and today we're gonna focus upon
the result he found for time now there's
one other piece of background that it's
really good to have in mind that
Einstein makes profound use of which is
simply this if you are moving at a fixed
speed in a fixed direction not speeding
up not slowing down not going around a
curve or a band or anything like that
then you have every right in the world
to claim that you are at rest and it is
everybody else you see who is moving
with respect to you you know the example
that we often use in this case imagine
you are on a train okay and you don't
feel any bumps you don't feel it turns
the train is moving at a fixed speed in
a fixed direction it could actually be
in the station for all that you know and
you look out the window when you wake up
and you see another train in motion and
for a split second you don't know
whether that train is moving whether you
are moving because all you sense is the
relative motion between them and from
your perspective you are completely
justified in saying that it is only that
train that is moving because you look
around in the train car the seats aren't
moving relative to you the passengers
the other passengers are not moving
relative to you from your perspective it
is as if that train is stationary even
if it happens to be hurling down the
tracks at 100 miles an hour you have
absolutely every right to claim that it
is the other train in fact everything
else in the world that you see out of
your window that is moving relative to
you fix be fixed direction you don't
feel the motion no acceleration you can
claim to be at rest good okay so now how
do we make use of the constant nature of
the speed of light and this sort of
obvious fact that you can claim to be at
rest if you're not accelerating how do
you make use of that to gain some
insight into the nature of time all
right now to do that we need a clock a
device that measures how much time
in any given situation and I could
introduce whatever clock
I'd like a grandfather clock I could
introduce a Rolex watch we could use the
time as measured by my iPhone any clock
is really as good as any other as long
as it's well made but for the analysis
that we're about to undertake there is a
very special kind of clock that makes
the mathematics and the physics and the
analysis much easier it is an unfamiliar
clock it is called a light clock I don't
know the history of who introduced it
it's a wonderful pedagogical device
maybe it was Einstein but I think it may
have been Richard Fineman maybe somebody
will tell me the detailed intricate
details of the history of the light
clock but what is a light clock it is
simply two mirrors that are parallel to
one another
with a single ball of light bouncing up
and down between the two mirrors when
the ball of light goes up we call it
tick when it goes down we call it tock
tick tock tick tock that is a clock
because you can measure durations by how
many round-trip travel times how many
tick tocks go by on the light clock so
just so you have a little visual picture
of that I have an animation which I
believe I can bring up good here it is
so there are two light clocks side by
side each has this mirror these mirrors
that are parallel to each other and
there you see a tick tock tick tock and
the counter on top simply counts the
number of tick tocks that go by so if
you want to know how long it takes
someone to whatever eat a pizza just
count how many tick tocks on the light
clock go by and that gives you a measure
of how long it took that event that
eating of the pizza to take place so
although it is an unfamiliar kind of
clock it does what any other clock in
the world does it measures how much time
goes by between the start of an event
and the conclusion of an event now why
do we introduce this particular strange
clock we introduce it because it's so
simple right it has no gears no quartz
crystal no cesium
vibrating and because it's so simple
it's in their mechanism is so simple we
can easily determine how motion affects
the passage of time on a moving version
of a light clock we can figure out how
motion affects the passage of time and
that's ultimately what we are after
so what we're gonna do in a moment and
I'll show you an animation but let me
first describe it in a more homegrown
way I'm gonna take one of these light
clocks
I'm gonna set it into motion fix speed
in a fixed direction that's crucial and
I'm going to figure out how the motion
effects that tick tocking
of the clock but before I do that
there's often a confusion that seeps in
people often wonder well look if the
clock is in motion like clock is in
motion the ball of light people wonder
might not simply go up and down and
might hit the sides bounce around maybe
I destroy the workings of a light clock
by having it go in motion and if I was
accelerating the clock there would be
some issues there but imagine this clock
has always in forever
been going at a fixed speed in a fixed
direction will the ball of light still
go tick-tock answer absolutely yes
what's the argument very simple if the
clock is going at a fixed speed in a
fixed direction then if I'm carrying the
clock for instance I can claim to be at
rest and all of you I would say are
moving relative to me and since I'm at
rest the light clock will do what it
always does
tick-tock up and down the ball of light
will travel how could your motion out
there have any impact on the inner
workings of the light clock since I am
not accelerating fixed speed in a fixed
direction claimed to be at rest
my clock does what it always does good
okay now there is something that does
change when you watch my light clock in
motion imagine it in your mind's eye
I'll show you an animation in just a
second the ball of light starts here and
as I'm moving from your perspective not
for money from your perspective the ball
flight will go up and down right it goes
up to meet the upper mirror and down to
now reach the lower mirror this clock is
in motion so you see the ball of light
go in a
double diagonal up and down and the key
thing is the trajectory the path is
longer for the double diagonal than it
is for the straight up-and-down and
because the speed of light is constant
if the light has to travel a longer
distance to go tick and a longer
distance to go tuck then it wouldn't
need stationary clock then it will go
tick-tock more slowly there'll be fewer
tick tocks
therefore on the moving clock compared
to the stationary clock less time will
elapse on the moving clock compared to
the stationary clock as you watch say my
moving clock go by you you work out the
number of tick tocks on your stationery
one it will be a bigger number of tick
tocks more time will elapse than on the
moving clock let me show you that one to
make it a little bit more clear so here
what I'm gonna do exactly what I did
with my hands I've got these two light
clocks
I'll leave one stationary the ones on
the left and the one on the right starts
to move and notice that that double
diagonal trajectory is longer so that
tic TOCs are happening at a slower rate
look at the counter less time has
elapsed on the moving clock from our
stationary perspective compared to that
on the stationary clock itself time
slows down on a moving clock is what
this argument gives us and key to this
is that the speed of light is constant
because the light is traveling a longer
distance at the same speed in order to
go tick tock in the moving clock and
therefore it goes tick-tock less
frequently less time elapses that is an
astonishing conclusion before Einstein
z' realization of this effect called
time dilation everybody thought that
time is universal Isaac Newton imagined
that there was this cosmic clock out
there in the universe relentlessly
ticking forward second after second
after second independently of who's
doing
independently of who might be in motion
and yet
Einstein realizes that that Universal
cosmic clock is a fiction it's a fantasy
the rate at which time elapses is very
much in the eye of the beholder it
depends on who is in motion and who is
doing the observing and that is a
stunning realization it cracks the
universality of the Newtonian notion of
time leaving us with an Einstein II
inversion in which time elapses
differently for different individuals if
they are moving relative to one and
other and we can now go a little bit
further and let's get to the equation
which will tell us the factor by which
time slows down on a moving clock and we
can work that out it's a pretty
straightforward calculation let's do it
together I'm going to do it right here
on the iPad that'll come up on your
screen and what am I gonna do well here
is my say stationary light clock and in
this case the ball of light is going up
and down to go tick tock and let's call
it a distance L that it has to travel to
go up and down and now let's compare
that to say the moving light clock and
the moving light clock the ball of light
is going on this double diagonal to go
up and down that's I'm really only going
to focus on the tick the tock is the
same so the ball of light goes like that
and let's call this distance L prime and
if you want to figure out the ratio of
time elapsed on the stationary clock
compared to time on the moving clock
well again more time elapsed on the
stationery compared to the moving clock
and that therefore has the ratio of L
prime over L so imagine just for
argument's sake that the L prime the
diagonal trajectory for the moving clock
imagine it's whatever three times larger
than the straight up-and-down
trajectory on the state
generic clock then the moving clock will
tick slower by a factor of three less
time will elapse on it therefore by a
factor of three and therefore the ratio
of time on the stationary clock compared
to time on the moving clock will be
three 3 times more time will elapse in
the stationery compared to the moving
clock if l prime over elbow is equal to
three so in one concrete example but
what we want to do is we want to imagine
that this clock here has a given
velocity called V and we want to work
out L prime over L in terms of V itself
how do we do that well it's actually a
straightforward calculation jut makes
use of nothing more profound than the
Pythagorean theorem it's it's really
quite beautiful so let's imagine that
you and I are watching the moving clock
in motion and what do we say we say from
our perspective imagine that it took a
time Delta s for the ball of light to go
from the bottom of the moving clock to
the top mirror of the moving clock and
if that was a time Delta s then we would
say that the clock move from here to
here
how far will ago well it's velocity
times time so this would be V times
Delta TS and we say that this
up-and-down distance is equal to L and
now you see that we have a kind of
beautiful little right triangle and that
will allow us using the Pythagorean
theorem to relate the the various times
at hand right so how do we do that well
we know I'll just write over here that L
squared plus V squared Delta TS squared
that's a squared plus b squared in high
school language is equal to L prime
squared now L prime squared I can also
be a little bit more cunning about this
distance will be equal to Delta TS the
amount of time that have took the ball
of light to go from the bottom mirror to
the top mirror times the speed of light
the constant speed of light C
so I can now set L prime squared equal
to Delta TF squared times C squared okay
that's great because now I can write l
squared is equal to Delta TF squared
times C squared minus V squared and
therefore L is equal to Delta TS times
the square root of C squared minus V
squared okay now I can take that and
plug it upstairs into our little ratio
over here L prime itself is equal to C
times Delta TS and then if I put down
the L downstairs that we just calculated
that is the square root of C squared
minus V squared Delta TS cancel out the
Delta TS and divide top and bottom by C
just to simplify and they get 1 over the
square root of 1 minus V squared over C
squared and that little expression is
the beautiful answer that we get - it
has a name they've actually give it
another color just to sort of highlight
it this guy has a name it's called the
gamma factor and it tells us as we just
derived that the ratio of elapsed time
on the stationary clock this guy over
here compared to a elapsed time in the
moving clock is given by 1 over the
square root of 1 minus V squared over C
squared so just to summarize that we
just found that delta T s is equal to 1
over the square root of 1 minus V
squared over C squared times delta T
moving so we are the stationary observer
watching that clock in motion and this
factor over here which I gave the name
gamma notice that gamma is always
greater than 1 because V is always
between 0 and C and therefore the
denominator that
having that expression will always be
less than one and the reciprocal of a
number less than one is always a number
that will be bigger than one so there it
is there is this beautiful time dilation
formula and you notice that for every
day velocities V is so much smaller than
C that this gamma factor is so close to
one that we don't notice it and that is
why for thousands of years we have been
fooled into thinking that time is
universal that time is independent of
our motion it's not independent of our
motion and if we grew up in a world in
which we routinely traveled at
velocities V that were near the speed of
light we would all know that in our
bones but we don't know it in our bones
because we don't live in that world
but Einstein revealed that at speeds
close to the speed of light
this gamma factor gets bigger and bigger
and that means that the time dilation
gets larger and larger and in fact I can
even show this to you in the little
demonstration that I'll bring up over
here great so here our two clocks side
by side and in this demonstration I'm
going to pick the speed of the moving
clock and show you how time elapses on
that clock compared to the stationary
stationary clock excuse me
so imagine that that moving clock stays
in a rocketship are picking the speed of
the rocketship okay let me put an
ordinary number I'll put in you know
whatever a thousand miles an hour let me
put this in okay thousand miles an hour
and I hit and there you see that there's
virtually no difference between the
ticking of the two clocks because the
slowdown of the moving clock is barely
noticeable but now I'm gonna put in a
bigger number let me put in say 667
million miles an hour okay now look at
what happens look at the hand on the
clock on the rocketship it is ticking
off time so much slower than time an
hour watch
on a stationary clock and this is really
how time itself behaves time slows down
for a clock that is in motion and indeed
if you imagine therefore going on that
rocket ship going out into space turning
around and coming back on your moving
clock from our perspective we will see
that you've only aged one year these
these durations that clocks are
measuring a real time it's like
biological time it's psychological time
we will see that you have h only one
year saying that round-trip journey then
you step off the ship our clocks on
earth ape and spinning around really
quickly and therefore it might be a
thousand years into the future ten
thousand years in the future a million
years in the future all dependent and
how closely your speed bee gets to the
maximum speed the speed of light so it's
a wonderful profound insight many
puzzles if you think about this things
that go into the name of the twin
paradox which I'm happy to answer
questions about this if you if you want
to ask about them in the comments
section you should think about it too
you know the basic question is you know
from the perspective of the person on
the rocket ship could you flip the
argument around and say the clock on
earth is ticking off time more slowly
than their clock think about that one
there's an answer for why that argument
fails and why truly is the case that the
person stepping off the rocket ship
would be actually younger than the
person who stayed on earth I'll let you
think about that one but that's our
equation for today the time dilation
equation that comes out of Einstein's
special theory of relativity again love
to hear your suggestions for other
equations I think tomorrow I will likely
look at the so-called Lorentz
contraction formula which shows the
effect of motion on space today we did
time and from there I I don't know
exactly where we go take her suggestions
maybe a little bit more of relativity
and so forth but join us and I look
forward to seeing you at the next
episode tomorrow okay take care